meal prep with me while we unpack some
drama I feel like we need to acknowledge
part of like the origin story which is
the gross fat shaming that Selena
endured when she posted this picture
right here first of all Selena looks
gorgeous she is a queen but in case
people don't realize Selena suffers from
an autoimmune disorder so if she does
not take her medication she could die
it's pretty serious stuff typically the
medication prescribed for a lot of
different autoimmune disorders are
steroids steroids typically cause weight
gain sometimes a lot of weight gain all
of which is uncontrollable and I see
bullying from adult women who a lot of
young impressionable viewers truly
admire I think how many young girls are
gonna die because they refuse to take
their medication out of fear of being
teased bullied and fat shamed like
ladies you have so much power so much
influence so much responsibility in this
world don't it up